hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Astro near now the
storm has passed that is good we have a
whole buttload of compound but compound
isn't exactly what we need we still need
to go find resin which means that I need
to go in a direction that I have not
gone before I've gone in most of the
directions but I'm just not a hundred
percent sure where to go and thankfully
it is finally dig and I feel like it's
been night forever like the whole last
episode felt like it was entirely in
darkness which is kind of cool but at
the same time I felt extremely lonely
and isolated and have no friends because
it seemed to be kind of similar to
subnautica I mean all my friends aren't
dead thankfully that's that's kind of
good except for that one guy my clone
that died over in the sandstorm in last
episode I seem to be abandoned here all
by my lonesome and I don't know if
that's planned by whatever space station
I was first launched from but uh seems
to be a bit of a stressful situation to
put anybody in but at least I got this
accident found that's it literally
that's all the oxygen you're gonna give
me there's nothing there's literally
nothing why'd you do that that's nothing
I thought you would have replenished by
then okay either way I gotta try to make
do with what I got and I need more
resonant then as soon as I haven't be
able to have resin I'll be able to make
what I need to make oh I found the power
in oxygen cave oh [ __ ] okay but at least
there's a cave in here is that resin
that is indeed resin was that the only
bit of resin is it just buried down
beneath yeah it is okay alright then
I'll take it maybe that just means that
I can find resin if I just dig in random
locations but I don't I generally don't
have enough power to just be doing that
willy-nilly resin resin baby resin resin
give me more give me more give me fuel
give me fire give me that which I desire
resin oh [ __ ] oh that is in the cave
whoa that is in the cave system okay so
the answer to the question that I asked
could I dig down beyond and just kind of
bore my way to the base uh the answer is
absolutely yes you can um there's
literally nothing stopping you in fact
why wouldn't you oh god I'm almost out
of oxygen oh and I'm in the wrong place
oh and I need to dig out of this [ __ ]
hole I might die I might suffocate Oh
No Go Go Go Go not to her we're not far
we're not far we can make it we can make
it we can make it we can make it go go
go go go okay
no no not suffocating no no no no no no
no not doing that okay we can now
research this maybe is there enough
power there is it just like one away in
the power department there we go okay
wink okay research away us did we get it
did we do good but that didn't do
anything
copper oh okay all right well I mean we
got more copper here which means that we
got two pieces of copper which is gonna
be good III think anyway I'm gonna put
this organic material over there because
I don't I think that maybe the organic
material might be fuel for fuel for like
a generator or something so that I can
have power pretty much anywhere but I
don't have that yet tank I don't have
titanium oh that might be an oxygen tank
so that I can last a little longer when
I go out which would be awfully nice and
goddammit it's night again all that
aside that's not what I need right now
I've got two pieces of copper which
means that I should be able to make
something new and interesting right here
so let's see what we can do resin boink
okay so we feel condenser yeah all right
research already got that smelter we do
need that eventually vehicle Bay ooh I
do have to aluminum
I don't have any more aluminum to be
able to make a vehicle if that's what it
means but I do have aluminum and that
would be the most interesting thing that
I can make right now so I'm gonna do
that I'm gonna take the aluminum that I
got here or no wait oh no I only have
one aluminum and then I have the means
to make another aluminum through
smelting oh [ __ ]
ah [ __ ] all right then we're just gonna
do the smelter then and then we're gonna
make the vehicle Bay next once we're
able to smell that red stuff over there
into aluminum I need so much more resin
why don't I have enough resin okay I'll
come back for you later
oh that's copper ore that's cool I do
have copper which I would be able to
make something with that all right so we
got Latta right we just don't have power
for this we do need to make some sort of
new power system there is there anything
else that we can make I can make a
beefed-up solar panel I do have enough
compound for that
okay I do have enough compound for a
beefed-up solar panel I also have Oh
copper I do have copper I can make a
generator let's see what that does
let's just explore the concepts here
because that could be something that I
actually do need because my base does
need power it cannot just run on solar
alone if I want to do stuff at night
that's so cool the fabrications of that
needs coal I don't have coal well damn
it that doesn't help anybody I don't
have coal well it was a good idea but
poor execution because I'm an idiot well
[ __ ] I should have made a wind turbine
that would have been better that would
have been way better goddamn it son just
get up already there you are you sack of
lazy second [ __ ] alright so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna I'm gonna put one
of my solar panels right there cuz that
way this will charge up a little better
because now I got a lot of stuff here
that needs a lot of power yeah what I'm
gonna do actually no I don't want to do
that yeah I'll do that okay I'm gonna
put my solar panels on there so it
charges up a lot faster because that's
what it needs to do and I need to give
it a lot more power so those are all
gonna charge it very quickly what I
could do is I could grab this power so
now I got plenty of power for the road
yeah I guess I can take one of these
with me I'll just take the one alright
so I got that get these out of here
get these out of here I've got compound
out the wazoo okay
I don't think I've gone in this
direction before or maybe I have and I'm
just mistaken with my life okay so I'm
gonna head out in this direction and I'm
gonna get some more material I'm pretty
sure that's where I carved out some
resin so no more there it's gotta be
something over here of valued I'm pretty
sure that sprinting consumes more oxygen
but I should be able to find someone
away unless I'm just completely unlucky
I mean I see an oxygen fountain over
there which should be able to help me
I've got plenty of power to be able to
suck it out of there and another cave
system over there so I should be golden
probably not oh please make it come on a
little more just little sips of air not
a lot of air just little sips boobie -
boop boop boop
really Oh cuz I needed to fill my bar
okay so I'm gonna go down to the cave
system and preferably I would find both
resin more oxygen and also another
research item yep more oxygen plenty of
I gotta gotta gotta gotta getta getta
getta getta good good good good good
okay so ah resin perfect so there's got
to be a more resident over here
somewhere
yes there is okay can carve my staircase
and get my resin at the same time yes
please thank you so it literally resin
must be just everywhere underground I
just have to go dig it out nice nice
nice nice nice okay so I'm gonna be
smart I'm gonna carve my way out of here
first and then I'm gonna do everything I
need
ooh more aluminum okay later right later
right later right later write lots of
aluminum to be able to smelt stuff okay
full there but that's okay I'm gonna
dump this power take that there I get
that are good get plenty of oxygen need
more stuff whoa oh man that is
horrifying what is that what is that
yeah I don't know what that is
oh I don't think I want to know oh god
yes so many goo peas so many weird
underground cactus things Oh what is
that ah
oh it's pulsating it's green it's
calling it's pulsating uh-oh that's not
all that that's not good it's attacking
me okay that's lethal
okay not good not good okay hydrazine I
don't need that I need resin which is
over there I'm just going this way
because there's there's um there's
oxygen up there no that's not oxygen
that was a lie okay that's a problem oh
thank goodness oh boy oh boy okay we're
good we're good
okay we got it we got it we got it okay
where am I where did I pop out oh right
here I didn't get nearly as much resin
as I wanted alright so there's got to be
more resin there's got to be right okay
so I've got enough oxygen and I've got
some aluminum ore to be able to smelt
down and make some aluminum because then
I'm gonna be able to make a vehicle Bay
I've got just enough resin to be able to
make another one or maybe I need just
one more stack of resume the way it's
fine because what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna experiment I'm gonna continue to
dig down near my base and probably will
find right why [ __ ] probably will
find rest if I'm not mistaken I might be
entirely mistaken but I'm pretty sure
I'm not mistaken okay KB do be put this
on
I'm looking in the way goddamnit get out
of the way okay be there blow there
smelt it up baby yes yes yes [ __ ] he's
got in the way
ah what Oh goddamnit it wasted one of
the aluminum because there was enough
space on it oh god damn it
well that's stupid alright whatever it
doesn't matter I'm gonna make another
one of these oh [ __ ]
all right I need more residents so what
I'm gonna do because I need more resin I
definitely need more resin I am going to
dig I'm gonna dig a whole lot and I'm
just gonna keep on digging till I find
something okay you know what I'm gonna
make something else solar panel would be
nice wind turbine I can make a wind
turbine yes I can make wind turbines cuz
that's gonna be good because that means
I'm gonna be able to get power when I'm
not here
that's good okay that is good okay made
a wind turbine I can put that right over
here yes come on wind blow blow wind
blow I'd find that didn't work but what
I can do also and I forgot about do this
I can make oh I can have a little mini
wind vane on me oh that way I can get
power from solar yes that's good okay
that's good because that means when I'm
on the go I'll be able to get oh that's
not good okay I'm gonna make this real
quick I'm gonna make a battery which
hopefully is gonna beam that I can carry
more power with me yes I can and then
I'm gonna get in my shelter in in in in
in thank you oh boy
okay so this is good I have extra power
generators on my backpack and I built a
wind turbine for why is the wind up
blow wind blow wind blow when can you
blow why you know blow as that should be
blowing like extra hard it's currently
winning up a storm why is it know why is
it not working
that's that should be working in every
capacity that's a wind turbine it's
clearly wind let's some sort of alien
not quite wind that we don't understand
no that's obviously what it should be
working so it's a little disappointing
that the wind turbine is not blowing
right now because that should be
generating a lot of power but the other
good thing that I've got is I've got a
mini wind turbine on me that doesn't
seem to be spinning either but you know
hey beggars can't be choosers
so what I'm gonna do right now is I'm
gonna go explore it I'm gonna go as far
out as I can just because I want to see
what I can find in terms of other things
like I could go out and find resin in
this resin right here which is kind of
convenient and I can get that but also I
should I know for a fact that I should
be able to get oxygen on the way and I
should be able to get all that stuff and
should be pretty well and set like in
that department so let me go hopefully
I'll find some oxygen if I don't there's
gonna be a short trip well I think
there's gonna be a short trip huh I may
have done goofed real hard ooh
may have done goofed Oh might have
goofed Oh seriously
goofy is happening oh no oh no goof Oh
goof goof real hard please cave please
have oxygen cave usually have ox yes oh
my god yes sliding slide yes slide down
baby slide all the way oh boy okay so I
gotta go in this cave and I got to find
more oxygen even though this seems to be
the scariest cave that I've seen yet I
love the way I slide down these things
pretty cool
soli radical bro [ __ ]
that the dye yeah that's the bad one
okay what's down there oh my god that's
terrifying nope not going that way whoa
hey whoa hey whoa don't do that to me
wait the way that's enough for now I got
resin I've got everything if I need
space I'll dump the resin and just go on
with my life but for now I've got enough
that I can keep going what I'm looking
for is I'm looking for other interesting
things like interesting landscape I'm
looking for interesting research
opportunities I'm looking for pre-made
rare materials that could be valuable to
me out in the field I'm looking for
pretty much anything and everything and
I should not be sprinting should I know
I should not so what is this literally
what is this is that a giant deposit of
compound OS compound but it's it's
massive okay I'm not gonna harvest from
that just yet oh my god
there's another one over there so if you
go far enough out you're gonna find
these literally huge deposits of these
materials
that's not compound this that's resin
that's a giant resin deposit isn't it I
bet it is okay that's nice but how do I
get all the way out here and how do I
bring it all the way back to my base
unless I'm just gonna be constantly
extending my base out farther and
farther and farther until I get to the
deepest reaches of this area I am out of
oxygen I am far away I'm not out of
oxygen but I'm about to be out of oxygen
slide baby slide oh boy oxygen oxygen oh
thank goodness
no stop sliding you're too cool come on
stop got oxygen and Boop okay that
should be enough ooh there's more of
there let me just grab that anyway just
in case because I need to be able to get
out of here got that okay we're good
this should be enough now I'm gonna get
out of here from this horrifying place
they call a cave maybe to bring me to be
okay back on the way I can't even see
where there it is there's home way over
there so what I when I think about this
there's got to be a way I can make the
vehicle bang no I can't cuz I used up
all my aluminum oh [ __ ] I'm an idiot
okay can't make the vehicle Bay because
I did stuff with the aluminum that I
shouldn't have done okay but either way
I can I can extend my base out I could
continue to extend my base out which
would be an option I just don't know if
that'd be the best option also what
well is this well are you are you
pulsating like everything else in this
goddamn planet oh you are aren't you oh
god it's like Lotus boob oh yeah that's
horrifying to look at ah ah why is
everything on this planet disgusting I
think this game is randomly generated
I'm pretty sure anyway but God
everything just has to be [ __ ]
disgusting one seat I don't know what
a1c would do but I'm gonna make it
because I got plenty of compounds so I
don't see what the problem would be wait
maybe what if I put this over here nope
oh maybe no that's not that's not
creating any power okay but either way I
got the one seat here Oh what does this
do what what is what does this do this
does nothing why why is this here why
did I build one chair something to perch
upon so that I don't feel so lonely a
night something to ponder my thoughts
with so I got plenty of resin so what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna make another
I'm gonna take this off of there put it
there I need to build I need to build
not that not that that not that I need
to build a vehicle Bay I've got some
aluminum but not enough so I gotta go
back in the cave I'm not gonna end this
episode until I get this vehicle Bay
because I said I would and I intend to
keep my promise okay going into this
cave because it's awfully convenient to
where I am
compound I need aluminum so I need
aluminum or or anything of the like whoo
[ __ ] Yee we're going down into this
thing we're going deep we're gonna deep
baby okay this aluminum no that's
hydrazine now what I needed
oh no oh my god oh how deep would that
go
what is this planet just Hollow holy
[ __ ] oh there we go that's what I needed
to louwman him here we go oh geez
that's power okay so we need to get out
of here limited window oh my god I
almost fell holy [ __ ] okay we're fine
we're fine everything's fine
everything's fine everything is
hunky-dory and fine I love life I love
being down here how did I get here where
did I go oh no which way oh jeez
I'm lost aren't I oh I'm lost I'm lost
I'm lost I am lost please let me out
please let me out oh boy whoa what it
okay I guess I'll research this I think
let me out please
I don't even think I'm going the right
way no I am definitely not going the
right way but I got a thing out there up
there okay that's good I need to get
more oxygen before I know I don't
actually the entrance is immediately out
of here
so bobbidi boo if this is the right one
which it might not be now that I think
about it maybe this is a different
entrance no yes okay we're good okay boo
okay so we got what we needed we got
aluminum resin so we should be able to
smelt up more aluminum at least two of
them which is good and then I'm gonna
research this monstrosity whatever it is
we should be good to go you research
that I'm gonna go over here and put the
aluminum here oh no I'm gonna smelt it
first trait trade platform trade
platform who am i trading with is that
why I'm down here just to be able to
make money oh okay okay gonna make a
vehicle BAE ho boo ski yay it just melts
into existence that's freaking awesome
okay it's got no power though cuz for
some reason the wind turbine don't
[ __ ] work I don't know why whoa look
at that wind look at it hey hey whoa hey
whoa
oh yeah wind turbine that's awesome huh
yeah okay how much resin do I got I got
two resin okay so I guess I can make it
all the way out here I already have this
prepped and ready to go so I might as
well all right Bobby - boo boo boo boo
boo BAM boom okay so trade platform
I need aluminum god dammit I thought I
had aluminum [ __ ] okay so all right you
know all I'll worry about that in a
future episode I'm pretty sure I'm gonna
need the trade platform because I'm
hoping anyway then I'm gonna be able to
trade out for materials that I need and
I won't have to count
we go hunting for it but the vehicle bay
is here and as soon as the Sun comes up
which should be just a little bit
it'll get power but it needs a lot of so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go back
into the caves real quick although I
seem to be getting a low framerate
somebody let me save I also got to hop
in my pot and save I'm also gonna make
some more solar panels here just to
speed things along preferably this is
all gonna go pretty quickly I need to
make another one and Shambu ski ok so
that should maximize the power yeah
that's going quicker so as soon as this
gets enough power it should have enough
to be able to make what it needs to make
and get what it needs to get and then
everything should be hunky-dory ok whoa
Rover Rover Rover all I needs is
compound I can make that I want to make
a rover oh I just used up the last of
the compound that I have but I know I
can get tons of compound there's plenty
of compound around here I gotta go get
compound I'll be right back
company boop-boop-boop-boop gimme gimme
gimme gimme gimme it good give me good
give me good you know good
give me all good more more more please
need more I need more more and more more
come on you got more you know one more
stacking you oh I know you got one more
stack somewhere yes yes four stacks okay
and then I can also get cuz I didn't
know what is this it's something weird
okay but I got four stacks of it which
means I should be able to make the rover
and then maybe I'm gonna need to put the
chair on top of that it's entirely
possible I don't know hundred percent
but I'm gonna try it because I like to
try new things
OOP adieu oh [ __ ] didn't mean to do that
whooping OOP OOP OOP OOP OOP okay and
shubbu ski and shubbu ski okay here we
go
I'm making I didn't even see what else
you could make why did I just
automatically default for the rover I
don't know I'm an idiot
well [ __ ] there we go can I put a chair
on it
can I put a chair on it like it's gonna
do anything I don't know if that's gonna
sure okay can I get in it what what
that's so cool I could plug in how do i
how do I extend the grapper do oh that's
so cool I don't oh man
controlling it is a little foreign to me
oh gosh there's no backing up in this is
there how do i hook it up how do i hook
it up I don't know how to get up there
we go okay alright there we go yes yes
yes I can put a storage on this I can
poo oh that's so cool
that is so cool I can put storage on
this and I can fuel up and I have oh I
can put extra batteries on it oh that's
so cool oh my god I've got a rover oh
man I wonder out how much how much I'm
gonna take it on a test ride woops sorry
rip that out okay so not a had a lot of
power not a lot but some decent range
and way better speed than I was getting
out of my feet oh that's awesome
does it provide it provides me oxygen -
it does doesn't it I think it do oh
that's so cool ah hot hole yeah [ __ ]
that is this is the coolest thing this
is literally the coolest thing I love
this so much oh this is so cool so
anyway that is awesome but that is all
the time that I got for this episode I'm
gonna figure this out more later I also
seem to be getting some low framerate
here and there but that's something
that's just a sacrifice of what we're
gonna deal with so I will get that later
but uh for now this is freaking awesome
I love this a lot I'll try to figure out
the low framerate in just a bit but
either way thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know what you
thought down the comments below
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
[Music]